[Music]
now all your fans want to know how
you're doing how you're feeling sad news
about the split no there's no other way
to say that that's a love Nicole I'm out
and that's that
John Cena opening up to et at CinemaCon
in Las Vegas about calling off his
engagement to Nikki Bella earlier this
month the actor was there to promote his
Transformers spin-off film bumblebee out
December 21st I think it's a wonderful
take on a franchise that the world loves
and I think they're gonna go on a
wonderful ride with us to the origins of
bubble tea now your coaster is Hailee
Steinfeld were you a fan of hers before
you do like her music
you know what True Grit was fantastic so
I'm a little bit a little bit long in
the tooth but it was interesting because
we both share parallels we both come
from live entertainment and we do film
as well I really enjoyed talking to her
on set about what it's like what her
struggle is like and what her life is
like balancing a film career and the
career in live entertainment
she's a very driven human being well so
are you I mean you're killing it this
doesn't mean does this feel like a
moment for you to be a part of such a
huge action franchise it is and I'd I
say that with a the most humble way I
can to me it to be asked and honored to
be involved in transformers like it's a
it truly is a major thing I'm very happy
to be being able to be part of this and
especially dissecting the movie back to
its roots bumblebee is such a popular
transformer and now we're gonna go on a
journey with bumblebee to answer a lot
of questions about bumblebee and I'm
just happy to be along feel around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]